Este sou eu e eu bati com o meu carro
duas vezes então hoje vou testar vários
produtos que eu comprei na internet para
resolver este problema para Além disso
ele está todo sujo então Eu dividi os
meus produtos em três categorias temos
os produtos de limpeza produtos de
estética e os produtos de emergência em
caso de acidente mas remover os riscos
do meu carro vai ser o verdadeiro
[Música]
desafio produtos de limpeza uma peça
pistola de água de alta pressão portátil
para limpeza de máquina parece ter alta
pressão
ok parece que
funciona ah eu sempre soube que youtuber
não era a minha profissão ideal eu adoro
lavar carros o re mosquito atropelei a
onde sai sai sai á ya eu não devia estar
a limpar isto com espuma ou
[Aplausos]
sabonete
é pá de onde é que vem tanto mosquito
mano pá eu desisto de lavar isto pá isto
não ok afal ser youtuber é mais fácil
temos aqui um limpador de vidros dupla
face ó ela já Cola isto no vidro tem uma
patilha qualquer aqui What Como assim
parece automático não pode não
impossível impossível vou já Abrir é
agora ai quase parti o vidro
[Música]
estava bem sujo por dentro mais sujo por
dentro do que por fora isto até acaba
por limpar bem o vidro mas eu acho que
não é muito útil para carros talvez em
janelas de casa seja melhor escova para
limpar o
carro com o material de mais alta
qualidade vindo diretamente
da Ok isto encaixa
aqui isto não encaixa olha digo-vos uma
coisa é bastante confortável adoro
limpar carros sabem Vou abandonar o
YouTube e a Twitch e vou
só eu comprei uma coisa para esfoliar as
costas para o carro agora é a parte que
vem um especialistas de carros Dark não
existe no carro existir ao verniz do
carro achas que eu estou preocupado com
o carro assim achas mesmo que eu estou
preocupado com o verniz do carro achas
Eu ainda tentei esfregar o carro mas não
adiantava de nada esta luva não serve
para limpar mas já Vimos que ela pode
ser útil para consertar os riscos do
carro fica até ao final do vídeo para
ver se ele vai ficar como novo ou não
produtos de estética olha vê Carlão tu é
que me recomendaste isto limpar o
espelho retrovisor aqueles vídeos
chineses que já estamos acostumados
colou o Sticker e naquela zona
supostamente ele não pega água Ok vamos
ver o que é que tem aqui dentro Eu acho
que vem dois aqui dentro
a Ok só veio o kit de limpeza Ok já não
é mau eu preferia a espátula
Mas afinal eles deram a
espátula
[Música]
Ok isto talvez tinha que ser usado com
água
né nossa que bosta Ok temos aqui um
carro
duvido ele só passou o paninho e sai
tudo a
ferrugem saiu toda também duvido duvido
Isto é impossível carro na socata tem um
arranhão saiu o
arranhão isto parece ser uma lixa com um
produto ui eu nem sei se eu devia pegar
nto com as mãos bem com dois Olha boa
assim posso usar este aqui e o outro lá
atrás segundo o vídeo da chinesa Isto é
só passar o
paninho vamos continuar a massajar na
força do ódio e para não dizerem dar que
isso é só para pequenos riscos eu vou
fazer outro teste então estão a ver
estes riscos Ok eu tive que ser muito
rápido porque estava quase a anoitecer e
parecia que o carro estava cada vez pior
temos um problema eu acho que eu risquei
o carro ainda mais com esta luva Então
decidi esperar mais uns minutos para ver
o resultado 10 peças de 20 cm adequadas
para a saída de ar é literalmente isto
um facto é que há cores que são Fuleiras
mas este Cinzento acho que vai ficar bem
no meu
carro digam lá se não ficou incrível
Vejam a comparação deste para este aqui
em cima totalmente diferente dá um
estilozzo à medida Sem dúvida Este foi
um dos produtos mais baratos e funcionou
produtos de emergência este produto é
incrível agora vocês pensam que eu estou
a agarrar um tablet e na verdade é só a
capa bom este produto é que é incrível
uma das Lanternas mais fortes da
internet Imaginem que vocês estão no
vosso carro à noite a passear por uma
floresta dentro e de repente salta vos
um urso em cima é sempre bom ter esta
lanterna para apontar a lanterna para os
olhos do urso e o urso Ai meu Deus tanta
luz e
Foge vem com um cabo USB aqui está a
lanterna que bonita olha para isto tem
só um LED eu acho que não vai ser assim
tão forte como dis dizem Ok até é forte
Ah mas eu estou a ver que tem aqui mais
tem mais leds aqui ok isto aqui deve
ajudar muito a trocar o pneu à noite
quando tá frio se vocês foram o pneu à
noite encostam isto à roda Tá feito aqui
não conseguem ver porque tá de dia mas o
Dark do Futuro Está aqui a mostrar uns
testes feitos à noite olha para isto
incrível tem este modo de luz este modo
de luz e mais este modo de luz Isto é
para vocês terem no carro é por isso que
tá nesta lista apito de sobrevivência
apito sónico de canudo duplo apito de
resgate ao ar livre apito de salvava
terramoto de alta frequência em aço
inoxidável a pito de Alto decibel se
vocês conduzirem e por acaso acontecer
um terramoto vocês podem usar em caso de
emergência este pito OK agora falando a
sério este pito é para meter no cu isto
promete 150 dbis sabem o que é que são
150 DB 150 DB é tipo um concerto Travis
Scot aqui ao vosso
ido
Ok Isto é muito alto os vizinhos estão a
olhar para mim e eu fazer estas figuras
Man ó pá Isto é muito estranho mas mas
eu consigo sentir o calor aqui dentro eu
gostava que todos vocês conseguissem
experimentar esta sensação mas isto é
muito fininho e concent o calor todo
aqui dentro
genial chea boca fazer um teste cá fora
para ver se isto funcionava mesmo
estamos cá fora a sensação meteorológica
é inóspita Está muito frio e eu aqui
dentro estou quente isto resulta reparem
nesta maravilhosa paisagem gelada e
fria ess aquele gajo está
320 ui já não aguento mais ok isto faz
realmente uma estufa vais já para a nota
a porque funciona mais uma compra
interessante comprei um dispositivo para
nós sabermos sempre onde o nosso carro
anda temos que baixar uma aplicação eia
bem eu não vou conseguir usar isto eu
não vou conseguir instalar a aplicação
porque o meu iPhone neste momento está a
fazer de microfone mas o objetivo disto
é vocês ligarem ao vosso iPhone e pela
aplicação Vocês conseguem saber sempre
Onde está o vosso carro Vem aqui ao
lugar do pendura levantam aqui o tapete
e aqui vocês vão ter um alçapão secreto
levantam um alçapão secreto aqui vocês
até podem esconder várias coisas podem
meter o kit de sobrevivência e podem
meter este dispositivo guardam aqui
fecham voltam a meter o tapete e ninguém
vai desconfiar se alguém vos roubar o
carro à porta de casa ou se ainda forem
a tempo Vocês conseguem ir à aplicação
saber precisamente Onde está o carro
isto nem sequer é um produto a trollar
Isto é mesmo importante que vocês façam
porque já tive casos de amigos meus em
que o carro simplesmente desapareceu E
se eles tivessem feito esta coisa se
calhar tinha o carro de volta bolsa para
recipiente de Tiago dobrável J
armazenamento de plástico
transparente saltou a tampa Isto sim eu
acho um dos produtos mais inúteis que eu
já comprei para o meu carro mas faz
parte do kit de sobrevivência Malta se
vocês tiverem um acidente e vão parar à
Selva o meu exemplo é sempre de na selva
não sei porquê eu acho sempre que se eu
bater com o carro Vou enfrentar leões ai
mano bati com o carro ai mano preciso
descansar bati com o
carro preciso mesmo de água para me
recompor Ainda bem que tenho aqui o meu
kit de bolsa dobrável de água portátil
hum
ah assim já posso Conduzir de
volta como está o carro está quase a
anoitecer o produto já ficou bastante
tempo aqui no meu carro o zuki está
preocupadíssimo com o lixo e eu estou
preocupado com o lixo e com o carro Ok
eu admito eu estou um pouco preocupado
porque mesmo com o jato de água esta
pasta branca não sai do carro e eu não
consigo ver nada que tá por trás a luva
até ajudou mas tenho mesmo que insistir
com a água Porque isto está difícil de
sair
Não o meu carro continua cheio de riscos
eu fui completamente enganado mas vejam
aqui o antes e o depois comentem embaixo
o que é que vocês acharam esta luva
também é uma bosta e o zuki também não
gostou e é isso malta agora vocês já
sabem o que é que podem comprar ou não
comprar na internet para vosso carro
Pois é este vídeo também tá muito bom
assistam
adeus